rizo bandha Rita Rizzo banned Rita says
good evening dr. Tyson is there anything
in China he's in a different time zone
somewhere evenings right so that would
be Europe or yeah
the rover okay there you go so Brazil
it's only three o'clock in the afternoon
there you go
so Rizzo says this good evening dr.
Tyson is there any plan for a Cosmo
season - mm-hmm well we're trying to get
the band back together for that right
and it was a huge collaboration art you
know artists and designers and right you
know and so so nothing's greenlit but
where we're trying to lean that way so
there's nothing to announce yet okay
cool thank you for that question it's a
great question it they like like they
love the first one that means they want
more hey did you like that cool video
huh well how about a bunch of cool
videos all commercial free plus
exclusive original content that you
can't find anyplace else all on Startalk
all-access calm